اذا في بخمه تكمن المعارك وفي كييف يتردد
صداها الانتقامي فعلى ذوي الانفجارات
استيقظه سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه ليس هذه
المره الاولى بل الثامنه في اقل من 15
يوما حيث نفذت روسيا ثامن هجوم ضخم على
كييف خلال شهر مايو الحالي واستخدمه
صواريخ كروز وطائرات من دون طيار رئيس
الاداره العسكريه لمدينه كييف اكد ان
الغاره استثنائيه في كتافتها مع القائها
اقصى عدد من الصواريخ وفي وقت قصير في
اقصر فتره زمنيه ورجح استخدام القوات
الروسيه للصواريخ الباليستيه في هذه
الغاره الى جانب المسيرات وايضا صواريخ
كروز معظمها تدمر حسب قوله اما وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه فلنتابع ماذا قالت
جنه القوات المسلحه للاتحاد الروسي ضربه
مركزه على مواقع وحدات الجيش الاوكراني
ومواقع تخزين الاسلحه والمعدات المقدمه من
الدول الغربيه لاوكرانيا وذلك عبر اسلحه
جويه وبحريه بعيده المدى وقد تحقق الهدف
بعد ضرب جميع المواقع المحدده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات